- Alright, everybody.
We are back and we have the cast
of "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel" with us,
Rachel Brosnahan, Alex Borstein,
Tony Shalhoub and Michael Zegen.
So you can see the final season
of the show right now on Prime Video.
And in honor of that final season,
it's time for a game all
about other famous missuses,
which is not easy to say.
Obviously I didn't kill it.
This is "Name The Missing Mrs."
(upbeat music)
♪ Name The Missing Mrs. ♪
(Kelly laughs)
- [Rachel] It's a theme song!
- [Kelly] Yes. You're welcome.
Michael has graciously agreed to host.
So Michael, I now hand
the control over to you.
- You sure you wanna do that?
- Yes, I do.
- Okay. Well, thank you Kelly.
- You're welcome.
- In this game, I will give a clue.
The answer to the clue is a famous Mrs.
either fictional or real.
If you know it, hit your
button and shout it out.
If you're right, you get a point.
(bell rings)
- That's the sound if you get it right.
If you're wrong, the other team can steal.
(Buzzer buzzes)
- [Kelly] Oh.
I hear that a lot.
- [Tony] Excuse me.
- Kelly and Tony are playing
to win a marvelous prize
for the left side of the audience.
- Yes.
(Audience cheers)
- And Rachel and Alex are
playing for the right side.
(Audience cheers)
- [Michael] So here we go!
- [Kelly] Okay.
- First clue.
I like when game show hosts
do that with the cards.
- Collect them, yeah.
- [Michael] Here we go.
Robin Williams in drag.
(buzzer rings rapidly)
- Mrs. Doubtfire!
- [Kelly] Yeah, I knew
that one. I knew that one.
- Okay, this missus is thick
and rich and her butter...
(buzzer rings)
- Yes?
- Mrs. Butterworth?
- [Michael] You got it.
(bell chimes)
- [Rachel] That was amazing.
- [Kelly] I was slow. I was too slow.
I was, I was.
Me too, we were (imitates button sound).
- Come on, we got a
game show to host here.
She was the TV mother of six kids.
Three of them adopted, yes.
- It's the Brady Bunch woman
- [Michael] Yes. What was her name?
- What was the mother?
The Brady Bunch, Mrs. Brady.
- [Michael] Yes.
- Oh my God.
- It's good, it's great.
- Wow.
- [Kelly] Look, look.
- They said you were bad at
this but I didn't believe them.
- [Kelly] Woo, okay.
- [Michael] If you're shopping at the mall
you'll probably find her
in (buzzer interrupts)
- Mrs. Fields Cookies.
- [Michael] That's right.
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] Nicely done.
Nicely done.
- [Alex] I am thick and
I know about treats.
- Dude, me too.
That's a good stop at the mall.
- I'm impressed.
- Okay, here's the last question.
It's worth seven points, so
we can even the playing field.
- We can come back.
- While her husband is busy making a list
and checking it twice (buzzer interrupts).
- Mrs. Claus.
- [Michael] Yes.
(crowd cheers)
(bell rings and siren blares)
- Alex and Rachel are the winners.
(audience cheers and claps)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Okay, on my show though,
everyone is a winner
because it's my name up
there. I make the rules.
So you're all going home.
You're all actually going home
with the Emeril Lagasse
French Door air fryer.
You're welcome.
(audience cheers)
This 26 quart multi-cooker
combines 10 kitchen appliances into one.
You can air fry, bake,
grill, make pizza and more.
Right on your kitchen top counter.
You're welcome.
That's right, you're all
getting the Emeril Air Fryer.
You're welcome.
(audience cheers)
And because Rachel and Alex won,
we will go ahead and put their photos
up on the Chicks Wall of
Champs who beat Kelly Clarkson.
One more award for "The
Marvelous Mrs. Maisel".
Give it up one more time for
this amazing cast, everybody.